pour en parler nous sommes avec annie
lacroix riz ce professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université paris 7
denis diderot auteurs de la note
d'opération en france de 1940 aux années
1950 aux éditions armand colin bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous 75e
anniversaire de la conférence de yalta
aujourd'hui tout d'abord qu'est-ce qui
fait jouer en bien qu'on comprenne qu
est-ce qui s'est joué ce jour-là en
crimée alors il s'est simplement jouer
des choses qui étaient prévus je dirais
depuis 1941
c'est à dire qu'ils sont le fruit d'une
peur du rapport des forces militaires
d'autres peurs du rapport des forces
général les états unis apparaissant je
dirais depuis la mort du blitzkrieg je
dis bien depuis la mort du blitzkrieg en
juillet 1941 comme le vainqueur il était
le vainqueur général de la guerre plus
encore que dans la première guerre
mondiale
il faut savoir que toutes les choses qui
se sont décidés ou apparemment décidés à
yalta étaient des choses dont on avait
discuté depuis juillet 1941 en
particulier salines en juillet 1941
avait présenté à churchill dans le cadre
de l'alliance qui se dessinait début de
guerre ce sont les buts guerre qui ont
été présentés à yalta c'est à dire d'une
part la reconstitution de l'union
soviétique dans ses frontières de 1940
hérité de ses frontières de 1917 la
demande expresse d'abolition
du cordon sanitaire c'est à dire de
l'ensemble d'état qui en europe centrale
et surtout en europe orientale avaient
été des voix d'invasion vers l'union
soviétique c'est à dire comme union
soviétique demandait dès juillet 10 au
141 que fuse réaliser les conditions
d'une politique extérieure nonne hostile
à l'union soviétique
et puis au fil des années et s'est
dessinée et au fil des destructions
considérables qui ont affecté l'union
soviétique du fait de la guerre
allemande ont été demandé des
réparations des réparations qui renouait
avec le schéma de la première guerre
mondiale puisque l'union soviétique
était le principal la principale le
principal acteur unitaire est la
principale victime des destructions et
par conséquent ce sont ces
revendications qui était de fait
accepter par les anglais il même
officiellement accepté depuis 1942 et
dont roosevelt ne ne voulait pas
discuter avant la fin de la guerre pour
une raison très simple c'est que les
états unis pensaient avoir suffisamment
de force pour que les armes
arrêté une fuse en mesure d'éviter ces
fameuses zones d'affluence car il faut
le dire la zone d'influencé est une
question qui a concerné bien sûr l'union
soviétique mais c'est aussi une question
qui a concerné l'angleterre et donc vous
êtes n'a pas voulu discuter avec
l'angleterre davantage qu'avec les
soviétiques
donc quand on nous dit quand on nous dit
que yalta a été si vous voulez la
présentation en france est quand même
très net et elle s'est aggravée jeudi en
france et dans les manuels d'histoire
dont avant les manuels d'histoire dans
les ouvrages d'histoire puis les manuels
d'histoire ont beaucoup changé dans les
40 dernières années
on est une vision de plus en plus noir
de yalta on avait déjà d'ailleurs une
vision très noire parce que deux
boulonnais mais paille alta il était le
grand absent le ramadan est le grand
absent il était le grand absent et il
faut le dire les archives américaines
sont formels roosevelt qui détestent de
gaulle
ne voulait pas entendre parler de
présence française yalta comme de gaulle
avait des relations un petit peu
compliqué avec l'union soviétique c'est
à dire avait besoin de l'union
soviétique pour essayer d'équilibrer la
trop grande force américaine
il avait été au rythme en passer une
bonne alliance 2 décembre 1944 avec les
soviétiques mais il a fini par dire pour
expliquer sa détestation pour yalta que
c'était la faute de l'ours mais non ça
n'était pas exactement la faute de
mesures sérieuses d'ours havel a
positivement à yalta qui consistait à
dire de toute façon on a discuté pendant
des années je dirais des des
attributions ici et là et quand la
question par exemple s'est posée d'une
zone française
salina diène écouté il n'y a pas de
problème les vous serez bien aimable de
ne pas la prélever sur la zone
soviétique vous arrangerez avec les
français voilà nous dire qu'on a un
petit peu refait peut-être l'histoire
sur ce point en tout cas oui on a
beaucoup refait l'histoire d'ailleurs
comme on a refait l'histoire sur sur
l'ensemble de deux états parce que vous
savez très bien que depuis surtout
depuis une vingtaine d'années on a une
idée de du fourbe staline qui qui
profitent de la situation d'extrême
faiblesse d'un roosevelt mourant et de
lits et dole isolement dramatique de
churchill qui comprend tout même ethnie
c'est de la boxe et de la reconstitution
alors justement heureusement on a les
archives je vous parle de refaire
l'histoire on va écouter
emmanuel macron deuxième et dernier jour
du président de la république en pologne
précisément après varsovie hier le chef
de l'état s'est rendu à cracovie
deuxième ville du pays et ancienne
capitale son but opéré un rapprochement
entre deux pays membres de l'union
européenne brouillé au sujet de la
réponse aux problèmes climatiques et ce
alors que l'union européenne vient
d'entrer dans la période de transition
post break cite le président français a
affirmé qu'il faut penser ces relations
en état je cite sur le plan militaire et
stratégique
le président qui est par ailleurs
justement revenu et on y vient sur
l'histoire de la pologne au 20e siècle
et la manière dont cela a marqué le pays
je vous invite à écouter et à réagir
après à ces propos alors un vingtième
siècle polonais qui n'est pas le même
que 20ème siècle français tout à fait et
je ne sous-estiment pas ce que votre
pays avait une indépendance nationale
retrouvée puis d'un pays bousculé par la
bim domination nazie puis la domination
soviétique et donc de ses balafre de ces
morsures du xxème siècle ont nourri je
le disais hier plusieurs sentiments je
crois très profondément vie pour essayer
de comprendre les sentiment
d'humiliation à plusieurs reprises et
d'injustice des sentiments d'abandon y
compris à l'égard d'une europe de
l'ouest qui a laissé un rideau tombé au
milieu de l'europe et ses camarades de
liberté est passé sous le joug
soviétique après avoir subi le joug nazi
et même lorsque la liberté a été
retrouvé peut-être quelque chose d'une
promesse commune s'est perdu annie
lacroix-riz votre réaction d'historienne
micro de même qu'il est chez nous très
courant de noircir les intentions
soviétique yalta on assiste ces
dernières années à une reconstitution
historique concernant la pologne
absolument stupéfiant d'abord il faut
savoir que l'allié polonaise de la
france a été une année extrêmement peu
sur le chef de la pologne pilsudski et
jusqu'à sa mort en 1935 a été d'abord
très hésitant visa et l'alliance
française il était pour les empires
centraux jusqu'en juillet dix ans 118
la france millions la victoire française
n'ayant donné la capacité d'avoir un
pays polonais grand dieu il est devenu
officiel comment officiel alliés de la
france mais c'est un allié qui hélas
très idéalisée et qui en tout cas à
partir des années 30 n'a plus été un
allié en particulier à partir de 1933
car comme on parle énormément de pacte
germano soviétique il faut rappeler que
on dit à partir de 1933 1934 pilsudski
puis son ministre des affaires
étrangères et successeur bec
parce qu'avec l'allemagne un accord
d'amitié pour dix ans qui a provoqué
chez tous les voisins slave de la
pologne
slave je dirais une désolation et des
conséquences dramatiques
il faut le dire ça n'a rien à voir
évidemment avec des lamentations de type
politique et on n'est pas là au coeur
des archives mais le coeur des archives
montrent que la pologne a une
responsabilité écrasante dans
l'écrasement dans l'abandon de la
tchécoslovaquie dont les principaux
responsables sur la france et
l'angleterre n'est tout de même ce que
les français les allemands appelait le
vautour ou la hyène polonaise a joué un
rôle absolument décisif puisque
l'allemagne a même concédé à la pologne
une partie de la haute silésie du
territoire de tes chaînes qu'elle a eu
dans les y en a un en lesquels
évidemment qu'elle a perdu quand
l'allemagne l'a occupé alors je sais
qu'il est très à la mode aujourd'hui de
dire que les nazis et les soviétiques
c'est la même chose
mais enfin si on regarde les choses
c'est à dire le sort de la pologne de
1939 à 1945
et ce qui est advenu de la pologne
ensuite je crois qu'on ne saurait tomber
dans ses élans ce voudrait y ajouter
quelque chose c'est que c'est
incontestable et vous savez que c'est
absolument lié par les dirigeants
polonais aujourd'hui les polonais les
dirigeants polonais y compris évidemment
dans une pologne ravagé et pillé par
l'allemagne ont été très favorables
finalement à quelque chose qui a
représenté un danger enfin un péril
supplémentaire pour les juifs c'est à
dire que comme l'avait très bien montré
le grand historien américain raul
hilberg dans la destruction des juifs
d'europe
les polonais comme les la droite
polonaise comme les la droite
ukrainienne a apporté un rôle
d'auxiliaire actif dans la persécution
et la déportation des huées la délation
des juifs qui est aujourd'hui qui est
fermement liés par les dirigeants
polonais mais qui est une vérité
historique établi
raul hilberg est un auteur qui n'est pas
contesté on peut considérer que c'est le
plus grand historien de la destruction
des juifs d'europe
on a fait beaucoup depuis mai il a donné
l'essentiel
il est formel sur ce point il est
incontestable merci beaucoup a nié
lacroix-riz d'avoir été avec nous nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage
d'historienne merci à vous